vamos lá é depois né de tantas coisas
que a gente ouviu aqui sobre essa
reflexão sobre a força das palavras
o padre colocando muito bem a us lula
mostrando a questão das questões do
caminho nem ea solange agora falando
dessa e através de um acidente como pode
reverter um processo tão interessante
eu vou tentar mostrar pra vocês através
de uma poesia que é de um contemporâneo
do fernando pessoa
chama-se josé régio que fala muito bem
não só sobre a força da palavra mas
principalmente o que a gente faz com ela
nesse momento do texas eu acho que ele é
muito reflexivo para saber depois que
você sabe o que você vai fazer com ela
com o caminho que você vai seguir
chama-se cântico negro josé régio vem
por aqui foi por aqui vem por aqui vem
por aqui dizem alguns com os olhos laços
nos seus olhos ironia e cansaço e cruza
os braços e nunca vou pôr a lei
a minha glória esta criar desumanidades
não acompanhar ninguém pois eu vivo com
o mesmo sem vontade com que rasguei
ventura minha mãe não não vou por aí
só vou por onde me levo meus próprios
passos
só que busca saber nenhum de vós
responde porque me repetir porque me
repetir vem por aqui prefiro escorregar
nos becos lamacentos redesenhar os
ventos com farrapos arrastar os pés
sangrentos a ir por aí a minha vida a
minha vida é um vendaval que se soltou
é uma onda que se levantou é um a
uma mais que se animou
como pois serei voz que me darei coragem
para vencer os meus próprios obstáculos
se corre nas nossas veias o sangue o
velho dos avós e voz a mais o que é
fácil eu amo longe a miragem os abismos
as torrentes os desertos ed
as estradas têm jardins têm diz
canteiros tem diz pátria tratados
filósofos sábios
eu tenho a minha loucura levantou como
um fácil arder em noites escuras e sinto
espuma e frank e cântico nos lábios
padre deus eo diabo é que me queriam mas
ninguém todos padres nem todos
todos tiveram pai todos tiveram mãe mas
eu que nunca princípio nem a cabo
nasce do amor que há entre deus eo diabo
ok ninguém me dê piedosa intenções
ninguém me peça definições ninguém me
diga
ei ei ei por aqui a minha vida é um
vendaval que se soltou
é uma onda que se levantou é um ato mais
que se animou
não sei para onde vou não sei por onde
vou mas sim que não vou por aí
efe am/an